three rings for the Elven kings under
the sky 7 for the dwarf Lords in their
halls of stone 9 for mortal men doomed
to die one for the Dark Lord on his dark
throne in the land of Mordor where
shadows lie one ring to rule them all
one ring to find them one ring to bring
them all and in the darkness bind them
in the land of Mordor where shadows lie
[Music]
today we'll be discussing a topic that
Tolkien fans out there have been debated
for decades what does the One Ring
actually do let's begin with what we
know from the movies at first glance it
appears that the wearer of the Ring is
granted invisibility we see this with
both Bilbo and Frodo escape in tight
situations by using the ring to
disappear
we know the ring does not have this
effect on its maker sour on which leads
us to believe that only mortal beings
become invisible when we're in the ring
they become invisible to the living
because they enter the realm of the
Wraith once they enter this realm they
are able to see the reefs in their true
form
but if they're to remain in this realm
for too long they will eventually become
a ray for themselves making return into
the world of the living impossible the
power of translation does appear to be
granted when we're in the ring in the
desolation of smaug when the dwarves are
being attacked by the spiders in
Mirkwood Bilbo appears to hear the
chattering of the spiders but it's not
until he puts on the ring that he can
understand what they're saying we also
see this of sand being able to
understand the language of orcs
but if all the ring offers is being able
to turn invisible and understand foreign
tongues then why are so many eager to
possess it the ring is more powerful in
the hands of the immortal beings of
middle-earth they may are as they are
often referred to rather than granting
new powers the ring enhances the
wearer's native power the Dwarven rings
helped their owners amass great gold and
the elven rings helped them preserve the
world this could explain why hobbits
turn invisible when we're in the ring
Tolkien often described hobbits as being
nimble and stealthy characters we even
see Bilbo being referred to as a burglar
throughout the Hobbit Tolkien even said
that this ability that the hobbits
possessed was almost magical so perhaps
the invisibility granted by the ring is
just an enhancement of the hobbits
abilities the only non Hobbit character
we see using the ring is Tom Bombadil
and yes he does have powers of his own
but invisibility does not seem to be
among them Sauron forged a One Ring so
he could rule over the wearers of all
the other rings whilst we're in the ring
he could see everything done by those
wearing the lesser rings he could even
see and govern the very thoughts of
those who wore them the ring gave sorrow
and the ability to dominate and control
the minds of lesser beings
Sauron infused a part of his soul into
the ring meaning that the wearer is more
likely to fall victim to greed and the
lust for power becoming more like Sauron
himself this could also be why the ring
seems to betray its owner in its
attempts to return to its master
the reason Sauron was not completely
destroyed when his seal door bested him
was because part of him still existed
win the ring much like the way a Horcrux
works in Harry Potter Tolkien's work
could have even been will inspire JK
Rowling immortality to the wearer does
seem to be a side effect of the ring as
the ring was created by Sauron an
immortal being who would have no purpose
for a ring that grants immortal life
Bilbo and Smeagol do prolong their lives
when they're in possession of the ring
but once it is no longer theirs
time catches up with them and they aged
terribly to conclude what we've
discussed today the One Ring was made by
Sauron in my r and was intended to be
used by only him an immortal being in
his hands the ring is capable of
terrible things being able to see and
control the thoughts of entire races in
the hands of another Maya
such as Gandalf it would enhance his
abilities making him extremely powerful
but the ring would slowly corrupt him
feeding off his darkest desires until
the Gandalf we knew was no more as the
ring was not intended for mortals its
effects are unpredictable and can rarely
be controlled you might possess the
ability to turn invisible or you might
unintentionally curse an entire race of
people for breaking an oath like a
shield or the corruption of the Ring
spreads quickly amongst mortals and many
have died because of the power way
promises what about you guys what powers
do you think the ring contains if any at
all and would you fall victim to the
allure of the One Ring